Governor bans carrying guns in
Albuquerque after 11 year old killed
Let's uh you want to pull that article
up could you have that there you go and
uh News Guard certified 100 out of 100.
I I I can't believe this Governor banz
carrying guns in Albuquerque after 11.
it's not just Albuquerque it's uh
there's like a Metro limit
Governor Michelle Luan Grisham on Friday
announced a new Public Health order that
she said will ban people from carrying
firearms either open or concealed in
Albuquerque and throughout the
Bernalillo County for the next 30 days
regardless of whether they have a permit
Grisham a Democrat issued an executive
order Thursday evening declaring gun
violence a public health emergency
this is beyond unconstitutional
but I will tell you this right now
I'm willing to believe the police with
smiles on their face will will arrest
you if you have a weapon
the order States no person other than
law enforcement or licensed security
officer shall possess a firearm either
openly or concealed with cities or
counties averaging 1 000 or more violent
crimes per 100 000 residents per year
since 2021. so because of that it only
applies to the City of Albuquerque and
Bernalillo County Luhan Grisham said and
can only be enforced by New Mexico State
Police whose presence in the state's
largest city would be significant over
the next month
we've seen this kind of things happen in
various countries happen throughout
history and they almost always I think
it's fair to say always
lead to very very very awful outcomes
sometimes it takes a little bit longer
for the awful outcome but uh typically
disarming the population by decree
results in active conflict between the
citizenry and law enforcement and um oh
I know all of these libs are going to
get so bent out of shape when I say this
but for those of you that know American
history you will know that the first
battle which wasn't really even a battle
of the American Revolution was because
the crown was trying to seize the
weapons from local militia basically
farmers who got together and said we do
not believe these laws are Justified and
they went and said okay well we're going
to come take all your guns from you and
they said no you're not
when uh uh we're setting up the show
what's the big story I always ask and
we've got this huge story about the
Georgia grand jury indicted voted to
indict three sitting members of the
Senate Republicans and only because the
Democrats like now we're not going to do
that it didn't happen even though this
is what the grand jury does
this is where we're at right now in this
country and then Brandon over here says
New Mexico just banned by decree uh
carrying weapons and I'm like no no
that's wrong that's wrong Googled it and
I'm like no this is just some kind of
like platitude there's some kind and
then uh friends like nope Santa Fe New
Mexico he literally just came up in my
Instagram feed the first time I looked
at it I'm like ah you know maybe this is
somebody being a little dramatic on
Twitter because you know sometimes
people you know they they see a story
and then they extrapolate something
that's not quite correct like it's not
all the way verifiable they just kind of
go their own way with it but sure enough
looked into it and that's exactly what
it seems like just happened I will say
Arizona didn't ban guns that some Tyrant
is attempting to and that pirate or New
Mexico thank you very much New Mexico
didn't ban guns some tyrants trying to
and it's up to the people of New Mexico
to decide whether or not that Tyrant is
going to speak for the people this is
this is the the uh inflection point
the question we have right now is is it
a legal executive order
and the question for a person in my
position is
what advice do you give the average
person
uh I first of all I think that it's
clearly unconstitutional there is no
provision in the constitution in the the
Federal Constitution the United States
Constitution that empowers Governors to
revoke the rights of any citizen under
any reason so or to create law fair
enough true
um so there's that so first of all right
off the bat it's unconstitutional you're
gonna have to have people get together
peacefully open carry peacefully
disregard the law and you're gonna it's
gonna have to be a it's not a law though
well this is a degree this is the
question I have
we my position is almost always you know
we challenge the law through the legal
system when when legislatures pass laws
it's something we have to get active on
with knocking on doors and filing
lawsuits many of these laws are unjust
and get removed instantly it is
extremely likely that this thing is
going to be struck down
almost immediately however the governor
did it on a Friday intentionally so that
she's guaranteed a few days of this
being in effect which is using the
procedure as the punishment
what do you say to the average person
this is not law
this is unconstitutional and I would
argue should be considered seditious or
illegal on the part of the government
should be illegal it should be a
criminal act to subvert the Constitution
it is actually the question is who will
the police in what direction will the
police start to enforce this
do we then say You must abide by decree
of Governor well that's not legal in
this country
in which case we would say to people
disregard decree of Governor well now
you've got police saying you're inciting
criminal actions or something to that
effect the law is broken the legal
system has shattered you're saying if
you tell a cop in New Mexico to defy the
governor that you're committing a crime
no if you tell someone they should keep
and bear arms regardless of the decree
you are now inciting someone to as per
the governor's view violate their Public
Health order under executive powers
which is not law but the police will say
you're inducing someone to commit a
crime so I did just look this up this is
kind of interesting because like I I
agree with a lot of that like there
there is no provision that allows the
governor to defy you know the Bill of
Rights that's very basic but they're
having State Police enforce this which
is why I was really curious what the the
New Mexico state constitution says about
it so article two of the uh constitution
of New Mexico provides quote no law
shall abridge the right of the citizen
to keep and bear arms for security and
defense for lawful hunting and
recreational use and for all other
lawful purposes but nothing herein shall
be held to permit the carrying of
concealed weapons
which was kind of interesting so this is
the New Mexico Bill of Rights section
two and uh right to bear arms is Article
2 Section 6.
and uh it's exactly as you said we have
it pulled up here and this was um it
looks like as of November 2nd 1971.
so the governor if the police
I'm hoping the police just say here's
what needs to happen we need a statement
from the head of state police publicly
right now to the Press
this is not correct it will not be
enforced the citizens have a right to
keep and bear arms you know as as
regulated and we will not
arrest anyone I'm sorry I've seen it
happen 20 times we all know uh the story
a story that I heard about it's actually
a relatively prominent a woman from
Pennsylvania was going to Atlantic City
she had a revolver in her purse she gets
she crosses the bridge into Jersey
and gets pulled over officer comes and
says you know I pulled you over and she
goes I don't and then she says but I do
want to let you in just keep make sure
you're informed I I do have my my weapon
oh am I my my gun on me I do have a
permit for it and it's here in my bag
anyway thank you ma'am out of the
vehicle please you're under arrest
that's a felony and wow the only reason
uh so this is a story that was told to
me by a gun shop in New Jersey
apparently it was a big deal the only
reason she got off was that her lawyers
pulled up a a a a case where a celebrity
was given a special pass what's her name
I don't know I don't know what his name
is it I was in a gun shop this guy told
me so I heard the story too like I can
they were they were terrified that this
story has gone around right there was
some celebrity who got a special
treatment their lawyer cited this case
and then the D.A was like okay drop it
drop it drop it we're gonna lose this
one it's gonna set bad precedent but the
only thing that matters to me is that
the cop with a smile on his face said
ma'am I know the bridge is five minutes
right there I could turn you around
right now and say just bring it home but
I want to destroy you instead he decided
I'm going to ruin your life right like
so I'm like there's a lot of people that
are a cab and there's a lot of people
that are very oh don't cross The Thin
Blue Line both positions are stupid all
right you have to have some amount of
policing in your in your society and in
your community and if you go to
communities that are riddled with crime
and you talk to the normal people that
are not committing crimes they're like
send more cops we need more police
because because we need to get these
people that are committing the crimes
off the streets if you go to places that
are high crime the police know the
people that are committing the crimes
they can pick them out usually it's a
you know if it's a major city a couple
hundred couple few hundred or whatever
you could lock those people up and
that'll solve a large portion of the
crime that doesn't mean that every time
a cop pulls you over it's a good idea to
tell them all your personal private in
information concealed is concealed hush
if a cop pulls you over I think you have
to tell about your gun you have to tell
about your gun right I I think they are
trying to create
physical conflict in this country
there's look these videos of the feds
arresting j6ers with rifles pointed at
them some like portly fellow walks out
of his house in his shorts like
scratching his face like huh and they're
just all pointing rifles what happened
in Provo Utah when they went in that
guy's house shot and killed him
it it appears maybe it's not the case
but it certainly appears like they are
doing everything they're possible to
provoke a violent outbreak this right
here in New Mexico is basically chucking
Dynamite into a crowd and being like
let's see what happens
yeah I know a lot of like the case that
you were talking about earlier where
like the the copy said actively chose
they made that decision to ruin her life
or at least make her life extremely
difficult for the next few years that
that's where like I've learned a lot uh
just being around like you know donut
operator Cody uh like my best friend
he's great I've learned a lot about
policing and different stuff like that
through his eyes and stuff like that and
a big thing that he harps on is Officer
discretion with stuff like that like
that that's something that and I think
that's where a lot of the Nuance gets
lost between like the a cab crowd The
Thin Blue Line crowd like the officer is
always wrong the officer is always right
like officer discretion is really an
important thing that is not utilized
enough and I know that there's a lot of
officers a lot of police officers that
don't live in the towns that they that
they police and I understand that
there's a lot of security issues that
can come up and and their safety issues
if you're if you're in a place that's
got a lot of crime and you're actively
throwing people in jail and you live in
that town then there's a possibility of
Retribution and stuff I get it but if
you have police officers that you see
regularly and you know you can have a
rapport with them and the police
officers can have a rapport with you if
a cop knows that you're not one of the
handful of of garbage cans that are out
there causing all kinds of problems in
town the cop should and I obviously it's
not every cop but the cop really should
take that into consideration so shout
out to Elon Musk uh for helping bring
awareness to this he he just responded
but it's all like his response is
already generating a reactions to the
the story I tweeted the story out holy F
uh and so a whole bunch of people have
have jumped on it that's what gives me
hope is that the this this was such a
bold and psychotic move it's like
dropping a boulder into a pond everyone
notices the bang and the massive Splash
just just shot them and the cops the New
Mexico State cops that are listening
right now or they're going to hear this
story have an opportunity to exercise
some discretion right now you got to
protect your citizens absolutely
especially if you you swore an oath to
the constitution of not only the United
States but I imagine to New Mexico so
that's their obligation and there's and
you know you mentioned the constitution
of New Mexico I'm sorry to cut you often
real quick but like almost every state
in the Union has something that
resembles the Second Amendment all of
them
every single one has something similar
it's not the exact same thing but all of
them have something like the Second
Amendment because owning firearms
is one of the things that is a clear
indication that you are free right
California doesn't have one
and it is
daily they must have you well actually I
don't know they never really did it's a
newer State relative to the rest of them
but but yeah so maybe Hawaii doesn't as
well but you know like seriously it's
like the the Second Amendment is
supposed to be you know Supremacy
Clauses means that it's supposed to be
the supreme law but you know so man you
know we're the culture War this morning
was was very interesting uh I thought it
was pretty good
poor Alex didn't really get a chance to
speak didn't really speak so I can't
really you know thanks for coming to
anybody but uh Brandon Wu is here and
the general sentiment among many of
these leftists one thing I love what
they do is they take tweets of mine
where I say something like Civil War but
they remove the context of why I said it
so it's just a bunch of tweets that
blankets say Civil War whatever but
it'll be like I don't know there'll be
an article that says something the
effect of Fallout extremists you know
opens fire killing so and so and I'll be
like Civil War and then they'll remove
that story and just snip the little
statement and then imply that I'm
insinuating that there's some kind of uh
or that I want to happen quite the
opposite
but uh in our conversation
every single time it comes up someone
will say to me touch grass right as the
old meme go talk to regular people and
my response is just do you think that
during like the first the American Civil
War that some dude walked out of his
house in Atlanta looked at his neighbor
and said do you want Civil War and then
the other guy went I certainly do ah
let's fight
now if you lived in New York and you
lived in in Atlanta you'd walk outside
and no one's talking about it because
your life was different you were focused
on your farm or your shop or your the
the the the the minutiae and routine of
your daily lives
everyone seems to think that you need a
mass mobilization of half the country
rising up and formally declaring
hostilities against the other half and
that's never been the case in this
instance the reason why this story is
alarming we've just quite literally been
talking about Lexington and Concord over
the past week when a couple hundred
Redcoats were like hand over your guns
and they were like not you know you can
pry for my cold dead hands
and then they tried
and that's considered a handful of
militiamen maybe it's a hyperbox a
handful but local militiamen regular
people who bought who had weapons saying
no was the first battle of the American
Revolution the shot heard around the
world and and to even further your point
like going back to the American Civil
War after the you know you've got the
revolution with Lexington Lexington and
Concord but in the American or in the uh
the American Civil War uh there's always
usually a focal point that happens and
it's usually some sort of government
decree of some sort because uh the one
in the American Civil War a lot of
people point to is when Lincoln uh went
to the South and he went to a lot of
Southern States and said I expect you to
send me 75 000 troops so we can go
invade the states in Rebellion yep which
is it was like I think he demanded a
North Carolina and a few others and the
in the response was overwhelmingly I
think we're gonna succeed instead yeah
so a lot of people always get mad when
we talk about the stuff they're like
you're not a historian and you're
getting facts wrong it's like okay dude
I read I read a couple academic
historical papers and watch a few
documentaries so I'm probably wrong but
the general my general understanding was
that sevens I think it was seven states
seceded before Lincoln was inaugurated
and then you had States I think it was
like uh Tennessee West Virginia
um
uh Virginia well not West Virginia but
Virginia itself because there was no
West Virginia Virginia was like you know
we kind of want us to seed but we
probably shouldn't and they're like okay
so we're not gonna then Lincoln said hey
these states an active Rebellion I'm
gonna conscript troops to go quell that
rebellion and that shifted sentiment in
these states to where they were like
okay now you want us to go to war okay
this is this has gone too far where we
want us to go to war with our neighbor
yeah yeah it was like not not go to war
with Canada or Britain or France or
whatever like you want us to go to war
with like the state that we border right
are you are you crazy but this this
shifted sentiment but I do think it's
fair to say that's that's actually we're
we're so far away from that Bleeding
Kansas is a better example of where we
may be today and the American Revolution
may have better uh analogs or the
Spanish Civil War but uh Bleeding Kansas
was a seven year conflict that not even
just Kansas but in the territories
outside of the actual states in the US
territories with the debate over which
state would be a slave state or not you
had people murdering each other so
I look at this history doesn't repeat it
rhymes
what happens today will not be a
one-for-one reflection of what happened
back then because the internet I mean
that's that's the easy one things are
very different
I have in in look man you know I'm
talking to Brianna Wu earlier and she's
saying like we need to stop being at
each other's necks calm down and you
know move this country forward
everything they're doing
does nothing but escalate and I mean the
establishment the machine the doj let's
I won't even take Democrats I'll say the
doj
when you have Joe Biggs get 19 and a
half years in prison
for for this stuff I'm like yeah you
realize that's just going to make
everyone angrier
they like to say that it's absurd to
bring up the concept of Civil War so I
asked a few simple questions of Brianna
do you think the people that uh stormed
the capital when Joe Biden wins in 2024
will just pet their hands and say well
good game everybody we're done or do you
think they just say we are still angry
angry enough to break into the Capitol
Building there's there's been no logical
assessment by anyone trying who has
takes issue with Barbara Walter Stephen
Marsh or I there's been no logical
argument against anything we've said and
these are those are two Democrats I'm
citing specifically who have said more
so than I that we are we are we are in
or actively facing Civil War there's
been no argument as to what the off-ramp
would be
foreign
that goes back to like the classic meme
of like who radicalized you you did
it's like it's it's those it's those
it's it's the actions of those people
that because they're just they they're
it's a lot of it's almost a direct
comparison to what you know people like
Jordan Peterson had said about Ukraine I
think we need to figure out what victory
is because it's like you know is winning
a good thing in in the long run it's
like if do you want to if you rub your
nose in the cat piss is that really
winning long term are you just building
resentment are you making things worse
that's and I look at what the doj is
doing
a video is just put up I think it was
Julie Kelly of Enrique tario on the day
of January 6. with her he's being filmed
they were filming this and he had no
idea they got in the building he was
surprised to see it and the evidence is
all there this is a fabrication against
him uh according to her tweet the feds
tried to get Enrique to say that he was
working with Trump or that Trump had
some involvement they wanted to connect
Trump directly to Proud boys so they can
put a brand name on Insurrection and say
Trump orchestrated it likely to remove
his name from the ballot Enrique refused
so they give him 22 years plus it'll be
22 and a half
you know what I said
there is something Joe Biden can do if
you want to simmer things down he can
issue a blanket pardon of all the of all
J sixes right now and he can say like
Shay's Rebellion he can say it was wrong
of what you did but we cannot survive as
a nation if we're constantly at each
other's throats that's why I think it's
fair to say for those that have spent
time already time served and for
everyone else we are giving you a good
faith effort they won't well they might
that's we gotta make sure that we don't
go so far as to say that the solution
won't happen you have to propose a
solution and allow it to hang
so I get what you're saying that that's
that's probably a good perspective to
have um that being said it will take
Democrats to stop the escalation like
Republicans can't like Republicans and
the people that are being persecuted by
the Democrats by the The Establishment
they're not in a position to say okay
we're gonna go ahead and chill things
out and the reason is because all of the
things that they're accused of are all
things that are legal like they they
fabricate stuff the guy that from
Infowars that's going to go to jail
he was speaking like
tario was talking to people right and
these aren't it wasn't incite and it is
such these are such tortured accusations
and they have to be stretched and
twisted so much to make them fit it's
ridiculous and because of that it has to
be the the people that are in the
position of power saying okay we're
going to stop using our power because
the people that are not in positions of
Power are not in any position to say
we're going to stop escalating because
they're not the ones escalating exactly
Tim you brought it up fonny Williams
actually refused to indict these people
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time